est ce que le port d'un professionnel de
monsieur benalla était justifiée par sa
fonction telle que vous nous l'avez vous
même décrite
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas assisté ni
reporting de l'audition du chef de
cabinet ce que c'est à lui à apprécier
ici
alexandre benalla d'abord est ce qu ils
sont de baignade à porter son arme dans
le cadre de ses missions à l'extérieur
personnellement moi je ne n'ai jamais vu
cette étude normes qui se voyait sous
une veste pardon
alors pardon madame de la conterie
posera une question tout à l'heure
madame de la conterie possédons parrot
donc personnellement vous n'avez jamais
dans les missions extérieures je ne
croyais jamais elles sont bien là parce
que c'était pas mon champ de compétences
et je ne voulais pas vu avec une arme à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
à l'intérieur il me semble effectivement
l'avoir vu avec une arme or outre une
séance de tir je crois hélas il a porté
merci cher collègue madame de la gontrie
merci président en général j'ai réagi
vivement tout à l'heure lorsque vous
avez indiqué concernant le port d'armes
physique de monsieur bénard que vous ne
l'aviez pas constaté peut-être une fois
revenant d'une séance d'entraînement et
j'ai indiqué que vous aviez dit l'
inverse lors de votre audition devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée le 25
juillet dernier à 9h30 du matin puisque
vous avez indiquée commençons par
monsieur benalla gelé vu porter une arme
bien sûr dans le cadre de certaines de
ses missions tout en précisant que cette
arme n'était pas une arme du
commandement militaire donc il n'est
absolument pas dans mon état d'esprit de
vous mettre en difficulté je
souhaiterais donc que vous précisiez
dans quelles circonstances
monsieur benalla porter une arme puisque
vous l'indiqué vous même c'était dans le
cadre de certaines de ses missions bien
sûr sachant que cette commission un
petit peu de mal à comprendre quelles
étaient les missions réelles de monsieur
benalla et si oui ou non il était chargé
de la sécurité du président de la
république
alors madame sur les circonstances du
port d'armes d'alexandra oui j'ai vu à
l'essence benalla porter une arme je ne
veux bien sûr je ne renie pas ce que
j'ai dit aux auditions
c'est une revient c'est que j'ai vu
également porter son arme au retour
d'une séance de tirs
parce que ce jour-là il m'avait il me
l'avait montré
plus physiquement si je puis dire c'est
pas voix